with its huge rings of ice and dust
Saturn is one of the Solar System's most
iconic planets
it's beautiful really
but what's it hiding behind those bright
clouds
well you're about to find out by taking
a stroll on the gas giant surface
if you can
what would it be like to fall through
Saturn's atmosphere
how soon would extreme conditions bring
you to a Frozen end
and if somehow you did make it to the
surface what would you find
this is what if and here's what would
happen if you tried to walk on Saturn's
surface
about 1.2 billion kilometers away from
where you're standing right now since
Saturn the sixth planet from the Sun
about nine times wider than Earth it's
the second largest planet in the solar
system
Ed by its signature rings of dust ice
and rock Saturn also has 83 moons
orbiting it 63 of them known and 20 of
these awaiting official confirmation
and with an atmosphere mostly made up of
hydrogen and helium this planet is
considered a gas giant
and this would be important to keep in
mind if you plan to take a leisurely
stroll along its surface
because you could just end up falling
right through it
as you approached Saturn you'd be the
first human to take in the glory of its
rings and its swirling atmosphere in
person
along the way you'd pass a few of
Saturn's moons like its outermost Moon
iapidus the icy Enceladus and its
biggest moon Titan
you'd make a note to check that one out
on your way back home
but for now you have a date with Saturn
soon you'd be making your way through
its massive ring system
this would mean you're getting close
Saturn's rings don't even stretch as
wide as the distance between Earth and
our own Moon
you'd fly past each ring in an order
that would scramble your understanding
of the alphabet
you'd go from the e-ring to the g-ring
and then Rings F and a
after that there's a gap known as the
Cassini division past it you'd be on to
Rings b c and d
yeah it might sound like whoever named
these Rings didn't know the alphabet too
well but that's not true
Saturn's rings were just named in the
order that they were discovered
you'd pass a lot of stuff inside the
Rings
their components range in size from the
tiniest grains of ice dust to objects
like comets asteroids or pieces of
former moons that are as large as
mountains back on Earth
finally you'd make it to the d-ring and
you'd be hovering just above the planet
itself
nothing left to do except make your
descent
traveling down to an altitude of about
1400 kilometers you'd find yourself
surrounded by auras of red and purple
they'd look so different from the ones
we have on Earth because of the highly
energetic forms of hydrogen in Saturn's
atmosphere
your fall through would suddenly get
more exciting too you'd begin to get
thrown around by powerful gusts of wind
in the upper atmosphere over the
planet's equator winds can reach speeds
as high as 500 meters per second
that's almost five times stronger than
the strongest hurricane force winds on
Earth
yeah so maybe the equator is not the
best place to descend
you tried coming in for a landing
elsewhere like Saturn's North Pole
well this wouldn't be ideal either
because as you descend a hexagon-shaped
storm would be Brewing below you and it
would be huge
spanning about 30 000 kilometers across
you could fit about two and a half
Earths inside of it
yeah at least the winds here would be
more favorable but just by a little bit
at the North Pole wind speeds only reach
about 90 meters per second
and I hope you dressed warm enough for
Saturn's weather because the gas Giant's
troposphere has freezing cold clouds of
yellow ammonia
the temperature here is about minus 250
degrees Celsius
don't think that sounds too bad well
good for you because that's 160 degrees
colder than the most frigid temperature
ever recorded on earth
now you'd find things starting to warm
up a bit as you continued to descend
next you'd fall through a layer of light
brown ammonium hydrosulfide clouds
followed by normal clouds made of water
eventually things would heat up to the
more comfortable temperature of zero
degrees Celsius
but that would mean that the conditions
around you would be comfortable
temperatures would climb higher and
higher and at these lower levels of the
atmosphere the atmospheric pressure
would be as intense as it is in the
Mariana Trench the deepest part of our
oceans
at some point you'd be wondering if
you'll ever reach Saturn's surface well
you'd be disappointed to learn that you
kind of already did it just wasn't solid
technically the surface of this gas
giant exists where the atmospheric
pressure is equal to that of sea level
back on Earth
so it was way back up in the freezing
cold temperature
there's not much you could look forward
to now except continuing to fall
straight toward the center of the planet
of course the pressure and the
temperature would be climbing higher and
higher
soon you'd find the pressure so high
that all the gacious hydrogen and helium
you've been surrounded by would turn
into liquid
yeah hope you brought a heavy duty
umbrella that can handle helium rain
but that's my bad I should have warned
you about this before you stepped out of
the spaceship
okay by now you'd be near the center of
Saturn
the planet's molten Rocky core could be
about 10 times more massive than Earth's
and conditions would be Beyond intense
here it could be as hot as 11 700
degrees Celsius with pressure over one
thousand times what you experience on
Earth
yeah maybe going for a quick stroll on
Saturn wasn't such a smart idea
went into an environment so hostile that
it would freeze you then burn you then
Crush you under the planet's immense
pressure
you wouldn't have a good time and you
didn't even get a chance to walk on
Saturn because as you found out this gas
giant doesn't have a hard surface
bummer
you know the only way you could survive
this trip is if you had a special what
if certified space suit
you know the the kind that still needs
to be invented
now if you did somehow manage to escape
from Saturn you could make a quick stop
over somewhere a little more manageable
like Saturn's moon Titan
approaching this Moon you'd find that
it's larger than our own Moon and even
bigger than Mercury
Titan's not just some boring Rock either
soon you'd be enveloped by its hazy gold
and orange atmosphere of nitrogen and
methane
the thick haze around you would look a
lot like smog back on Earth
but the worst part is once you get close
to the moon's surface the atmospheric
pressure would make you feel as if you
were diving 15 meters deep in the ocean
and at minus 180 degrees Celsius it
would be bone chillingly cold
but the good news is is after all that
falling back on Saturn you'd finally be
able to stretch those legs out and work
on your step count
yeah you'd go for a walk along Titan's
Rock Hard Water Ice
strolling along Titan's surface you'd
encounter all kinds of interesting
features
the surface itself would be dark and
covered in what would first seem like
coffee grounds
these hydrocarbon grains would generate
massive Dunes almost like the sand dunes
back on Earth
and there would be other things that
would blow your mind too you'd discover
rivers and lakes only instead of water
they'd be full of liquid methane and
ethane
there would also be volcanoes spewing
liquid water instead of lava
is it just me or is everything on this
Moon just slightly off
now who knows this may not sound all
that bad to you maybe you'd even
entertain the idea of settling down on
Titan for good
well that's a story
for another
what if